[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello America hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in June of 1775 the Continental Congress
created a unified army out of the
revolutionary forces encamped around
Boston and New York and named after the
great George Washington
commander-in-chief the Continental Army
suffered a bitter winter of Valley Forge
found glory across the waters of the
Delaware and seized victory from
Cornwallis of Yorktown our army man the
air it rained the ramparts it took over
the airports it did everything it had to
do and at Fort McHenry under the Rockets
red glare it had nothing but victory and
when Dawn came their star-spangled
banner waved defiant we had a lot of
rain I stood in the rain to teleprompter
went out so ad
yeah the teleprompter went out it kept
going on and then at the end it just
went out it went kaput so I could have
said and actually right in the middle of
that sentence it went out and that's not
a good feeling when you're standing in
front of millions of millions of people
on television and I don't know what the
final count woods but that went all the
way back to the Washington Monument and
I guess the rain knocked out the
teleprompter so but no it's not that I I
knew this speech very well so I was able
to do without a teleprompter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]